Oh
ciabatta I've never had any like energy
drinks or anything like that I don't
have a logic reaction to caffeine but I
just stay away from caffeine I don't
drink coffee or any sort of caffeine
it's not like I've been actively
avoiding I just always kind of seemed
disgusted it's pink right
I think it's pink I'm not looking
forward to this oh my god hey take the
bull by the horns this is very exciting
here we go
smells like pink soda
it's not even pink it's like yellow it's
kind of like carbonated classier this is
like drinking what's inside a
highlighter it's sort of tastes like
horse glue it's not as bad as I thought
it would be it has a flavor actually
doesn't taste that bad yeah it's not as
bad now I think I'm getting used to it
tastes like bad decisions it's not how
drinking liquids should feel it was
overwhelming at first like it was really
strong and then I guess I just got used
to it real fast I mean I feel like once
you have won that it's like rest is
history
I kind of expected to try it just
immediately Hulk out and flip the table
over and not get any of that it doesn't
taste bad like I said but I did compared
to Elmer's food I probably would have
died without drinking dreadful that
wasn't for this video
but now the depakote did it
Oh